be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I wanted to do here was revisit
my series on common concepts and have a
discussion about some of the most
powerful items in comic books ranging
from the anti-life equation to the heart
of the universe and to kick this off I
wanted to take some time to focus on the
ultimate nullifier the only issue here
is that while the ultimate nullifier
appears in around 94 issues of Marvel
Comics it's only actually used in any
real capacity about three or four times
and so the ultimate nullifier first
appeared in Marvel Comics as part of the
original Galactus trilogy in fantastic
four issues 48 through 50 written by
Jack Kirby and Stan Lee while I haven't
been able to locate a reason for its
creation due to the fact that Stan Lee
is never offered an explanation and Jack
Kirby's deceased because Galactus was
introduced as such a powerful foe on a
universal scale a weapon of some kind
needed to contain equal power or at
least enough to force Galactus into
retreat taking place in issue number 50
with the uatu the watcher abandoning his
vow of non-intervention Chinese storm of
the Fantastic Four was instructed to
travel to Galactus his home base of
tattoo and locate the nullifier handing
it over to Reed Richards who in turn
threatened Galactus and this original
appearance no information was offered on
what the nullifier was capable of or why
Galactus was afraid of it instead the
nullifier was used as an intricate piece
of the existing Fantastic Four lore
which could offer some measure of
curiosity among fans as to what resided
out beyond Earth now following this the
nullifier remained absent entirely for
Marvel Comics for 26 years living into
1992 and the start of jim Starlin
infinity war coming out of the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline which concluded with
Adam warlock taking the gauntlet for
himself during infinity war issue number
2 it was revealed that Adam warlock it
subconsciously split his mind into three
forms one of pure evil which reformed as
a villain Magus one appear good taking
the form of goddess and Adam warlock
himself who remained neutral as a result
the Living Tribunal decreed that because
Adam warlock was devoid of anger or love
but also had no true value of life due
to his lack of ties to any one being the
garland was deep powered by the Living
Tribunal who
Adam warlock to disperse the gems
accordingly using this as a jumping-off
platform with Maggie's traveling the
multiverse and seizing a multitude of
cosmic cubes for himself as well as
reassembly the Infinity Gauntlet and
having it repowered the various heroes
of Earth and across the universe came
together including Galactus Thanos and
others looking to the power that Magus
possessed with the multiverse the cosmic
cubes and the Infinity Gauntlet the
analyst offered a full explanation of
the ultimate nullifier stating that it
possessed the ability to annihilate any
object wiping it from existence entirely
however unlike the Cosmic Cube or the
Infinity Gauntlet the nullifier does not
function as a gun with a simple trigger
instead the nullifier is more akin to a
battery requiring a full charge and can
only be used by someone with a noble
soul having the nullifier over the
quasar the protector of the universe
would in the quantum bands the nullifier
saw his final use during the infinity
war when quasar attempted to turn it on
Magus only to be annihilated himself
when Magus used the newly activated
Infinity Gauntlet to turn the nullifiers
energies on quasar now following this
the nullifier fell into the realm of
obscurity again leading into 2001 and
the introduction of a practice coming
out of Carlos Pacheco's run a fantastic
4 which saw Galactus transitioning from
consuming planets to only consuming
sentient life the lack of energy that
came with Centene being cycle actus into
a state of madness and perpetual hunger
and listing the forces of the Shiar the
Kree the scrolls the Nova Corps and
humanity the Silver Surfer led a war
against Galactus eventually turning the
machines of tattoo against the devourer
of worlds as a result and following
Galactus is death a wreck home was
offered stating that at the beginning of
the multiverses creation a being of
complete anarchy and chaos reigned
alongside eternity christening itself
Abraxas and existing on a multiversal
scale the story also revealed that
Galactus had operated as a gatekeeper
preventing Abraxas from escaping his
imprisonment and running amok
however with Galactus dead Abraxas
begins a reign of terror that expands
into the multiverse where he annihilates
countless versions of Galactus from a
multitude of realities leading into the
Fantastic Four hunting for the nola fire
using various multiversal clues to his
existence the location of the nola fire
was discovered by the Fantastic Four
but seized by Abraxas owing to the
nullifier being the only object which
could end his reign the sitting an army
to eliminate the Earth's heroes Franklin
Richards power to control reality was
used in conjunction with this
extreme intelligence allowing the two to
resurrect lactis who seized control of
the nullifier from Abraxas however with
an Ola fire falling in the hands of Reed
Richards the entirety of Marvel's
multiverse was reset when Reed destroyed
all things in existence and remade them
up to the moment when a practice escaped
which in turn set all things back to
normal now following this as far as I've
been able to tell the nullifier made no
real significant appearances in Marvel
Comics instead the nullifier showed up
in a couple of comics from Hickman's
Fantastic Four as an object that Reed
referenced during his recollections on
first encountering Galactus as well as
in the home of a watching The Watcher
during the original sin storyline while
receiving a visit from Nova Sam
Alexander that said in terms of almost
hierarchy of objects in their power the
nullifier is a bit of a quagmire where
the Infinity Gauntlet was able to trump
the power of the nullifier the nullifier
itself was not at full charge instead he
was only at a fraction of its normal
strength and so we can't make an
accurate argument on which one is
stronger at the same time the nullifier
has never been used against the power of
a cosmic cube leaving us no real answer
on where it lies instead because the
nullifier has the power to wipe out all
things in existence up to and including
the multiverse we can largely assume
that if at full strength and if being
wielded by someone with the highest
intelligence and force of will the
nullifier may trump the gauntlet another
nullifiers wielder could simply
annihilate the gauntlet from existence
but again at this point it's really just
guesswork well that being said we're
gonna bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it
now I'll catch you guys later peace